call of duty warzone fans including
myself have been hungry for more
information about the game's sequel
warzone 2.0 fortunately we got a big
plate of food at today's call of duty
next event including things like the
release date the new map and how it
differs from the original war zone let's
start with the new location call of duty
war zone 2.0 map is called al-mazra and
it takes place in the desert of a
fictional region of western asia some
points of interest include quarry
airport and almazra city just to name a
few and there seems to be nuggets of
nostalgia just sprinkled all over the
map this map also features a river that
runs through the middle offering
seasoned warzone players a new way to
traverse a call of duty br and new ways
to move around the map will surely come
in handy when the circle starts to close
or should i say when the circles start
to close war zone 2.0 will have a brand
new circle mechanic with multiple
circles appearing and changing the end
game scenarios when they eventually
combine into one again and when you
happen to fall victim to the gas or an
enemy player you'll be greeted with the
game's revamped gulag 2.0 where players
must battle it out 2v2 instead of the
normal 1v1 arena this second chance
gulag will include the need to loot for
weapons deal with something called the
jailer and more almazra will also
feature areas that are controlled by an
ai faction these sections are called
strongholds the developer says this
addition of ai is meant to add higher
stakes and more realistic combat
scenarios to the warzone experience and
this is just part of infinity ward's new
use of advanced ai in modern warfare 2
and war zone 2.0 which the developer
previously discussed as having the goal
to make lifelike enemies and friendlies
who will check corners actively protect
their lives and dramatically react to
player choices another hard to keep
secret was the previously leaked dmz
mode which was officially announced to
be included in warzone 2.0 at launch dmz
is described as an all-new sandbox
experience but they didn't go in depth
like i wish they would have another new
feature i wish they went more in depth
on during the multiplayer section was
raids raids are a first for the call of
duty series and are described as a whole
new experience for the franchise they
take the form of a three-player co-op
engagement that activision says will
require teamwork and strategic puzzle
solving in between intense firefights
the company also confirmed raids are
coming after launch but didn't say
whether or if there might be an extra
fee associated with playing them finally
players can expect warzone 2 to be
combating cheaters on day one call of
duty's ricochet anti-cheat server
protections and kernel level driver will
be active globally for the launch of
both war zone 2.0 and modern warfare 2.
infinity ward also announced ricochet
has been upgraded and improved with new
features to better keep hackers at bay
war zone 2.0 will launch for free on
november 16th and i want to know what
you think of all the new changes and
gameplay features in the comments below
i'm no good at war zone but i am very
excited to try out 2.0 when it drops in
november and i'm even more excited to
play the call of duty modern warfare 2
beta when it drops tomorrow on
playstation
i'm really waiting for the pc one but
i'm gonna jump into the playstation one
until the pc one rolls around and we're
gonna be live streaming the playstation
one tomorrow at 1 30 pm eastern
10 a.m whoops i'm at 10 30 a.m pacific
time 10 30 pacific time so jump in if
you want to check out the gameplay and
maybe experience a little fomo if you
only have a pc or xbox so
see you tomorrow
you